McDonnell Lawler for the UFC but too
late championship of the world Robbie
Lawler is a man on a mission right now
and he's very motivated to defend his
title for the first time this is really
do or die time I'm less hungry now that
I have a title if anything I'm more
hungry I'm ready to fight I'm a fighter
this is Who I am
a title fight we have had tonight we'll
leave with the Bell Lawler and McDonald
back and forth willing to stand and
trade it looked like we might have a new
champion
by far the best round for Rory MacDonald
in ruthless Robbie Lawler Joe we've been
watching him for over a decade
Robbie is showing tensions in this fight
we're seeing a thinking
I'm seeing a guy was still growing and
learning mean Robbie even said the other
day Joe that he's grown as a fighter or
last-second marks well they say that
about a guy becomes a champion when he
when the guy yeah comes a champion
confidence grows and you saw that from
Robbie as he's standing there being
introduced he was loving that he's
enjoying it so much more animated than
we've seen from in the past I don't
think he's ever looked better footwork
outstandings precise with the jab
scoring the combinations what a title
well over the solid kick he's doing a
really good job of timing his shots
front kick to the body by McDonald
tada he's a mass of blood
oh great you don't sauce
he's got one leg in in between them is
lilies in half guard here looking for
the armbar looking for the finish
he's in the full-mouth Joe McDonald gets
hit by that right kid oh you heard
don't Walter wait Jeffrey what a fight
what a fight and win a decisive ending
but a flight with huge
really pushed to the limit on the brink
of losing his title came back and
stopped Rory MacDonald in the final
round amazing and let's see that from
another angle
you
you